- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Mes
chers collègues,
deux drames ont touché
notre pays ce dimanche.
Six personnes ont perdu la vie
dans une avalanche.
A Marseille, dans le centre-ville,
un immeuble de quatre étages
s'est effondré.
Six personnes sont décédées
et au moins deux
sont toujours recherchées.
En notre nom à tous,
je souhaite adresser mes pensées
aux victimes,
à leurs familles et à leurs
proches.
L'Assemblée nationale se tient à
leurs côtés et aux côtés des
forces de secours mobilisées, dont
je salue l'engagement
inconditionnel.
Je vous invite à respecter une
minute de silence en leur mémoire.
Je vous remercie.
Je voudrais vous indiquer que nous
accueillons aujourd'hui, à
l'Assemblée nationale, une
nouvelle députée élue le 2 avril
2023 députée de la 1re
circonscription de l'Ariège.
Bienvenue à vous, ma chère
collègue.
L'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement.
La première d'entre elles va être
posée par le groupe Les
Républicains.
Monsieur Nicolas Forissier, vous
avez la parole.
- Nicolas Forissier: Merci.
Madame la Première ministre,
messieurs les ministres de
l'Agriculture et du Commerce
extérieur, à partir du 25 avril,
la France ne pourra plus exporter
sa production céréalière dans
certains pays très demandeurs,
conséquence d'une décision de
l'Autorité de sécurité alimentaire
qui interdit l'utilisation d'un
insecticide utilisé pour traiter
les cargaisons de céréales dans
les cales des bateaux.
La filière céréalière, cinquième
exportatrice mondiale, est dans
une impasse totale.
L'utilisation de ce produit est
exigée dans le cahier des charges
de nombreux pays, comme l'Algérie.
Ce produit est communément utilisé
dans l'ensemble des pays de
l'Union Européenne.
Encore une fois, la France
s'auto-mutile dans cette décision,
puisque nous ne pourrons pas
exporter plus de 11 millions de
tonnes de céréales dans des pays
qui sont pourtant nos clients
depuis très longtemps.
Les céréales traitées par cette
substance ne seront pas concernées
par cette décision de l'Autorité
de sécurité alimentaire.
Certains pays ont besoin de notre
blé et pourraient se trouver dans
une situation d'impasse.
Monsieur le ministre, comment cet
organisme peut-il prendre une
telle décision sans en avoir
discuté avec le gouvernement?
Comment peut-il prendre une
décision aussi importante sans
mesurer les conséquences de cette
décision sur la vie quotidienne de
nos entrepreneurs, de nos
agriculteurs et de nos ports
français?
On imagine qu'on va pouvoir passer
par Anvers et par Gênes, mais cela
va créer plus de carbone dans
l'atmosphère.
Comment cet organisme peut-il
motiver sa décision qui ignore le
droit européen en vigueur?
Il outrepasse son champ de
compétences.
Il s'octroie le droit d'éviter des
normes dans le secteur de
l'exportation.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci, mon
cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur
Olivier Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député, vous avez raison, ce
produit est utilisé principalement
sur le blé et est requis pour les
exportations par un certain nombre
de pays que nous livrons,
notamment les pays du Maghreb et
certains pays d'Afrique comme la
Côte d'Ivoire ou le Sénégal.
C'est plusieurs millions de tonnes
de blés qui sont concernées.
Cette décision interpelle le
gouvernement, et ce, d'autant que
ce produit n'est pas interdit au
niveau européen.
Le cadre juridique au niveau
européen est clair.
Il est permis de l'utiliser,
notamment pour les exportations
lorsque les pays exportateurs
requièrent son utilisation.
Il y encore des clarifications
juridiques à apporter, mais je
peux vous garantir que d'ici le 25
avril, les décisions seront prises
pour que les exportations puissent
se poursuivre.
C'est important pour nos
agriculteurs et pour nos
exportations, mais c'est surtout
important pour les pays
importateurs.
C'est une question de sécurité
alimentaire mondiale et c'est
également une question
géopolitique dans le cadre de la
guerre actuelle de la Russie en
Ukraine.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Manuel Bompard.
- Manuel Bompard: Madame la
Première ministre, dimanche, à
0h46, une explosion a frappé
soudainement le 17, rue de Tivoli
à Marseille.
L'immeuble s'est effondré dans la
foulée, emportant ses habitants
dans les décombres.
A l'heure où je parle, six
personnes ont perdu la vie, deux
sont encore portées disparues et
plus de 200 ont dû quitter leur
logement.
Nos pensées vont aux proches des
victimes, des délogés et à toutes
les personnes frappées par ce
drame.
Je tiens à souligner ici le
dévouement des marins-pompiers de
Marseille, des sapeurs-pompiers,
des effectifs de la protection
civile, des policiers municipaux
et nationaux et de toutes les
femmes et les hommes mobilisés
sans relâche depuis plus de 60
heures dans des conditions de
dangerosité extrême.
Je tiens à saluer aussi la
solidarité extraordinaire dont
font preuves les Marseillaises et
les Marseillais, lourdement
meurtris déjà il y a quatre ans
dans la catastrophe de la rue
d'Aubagne, même si les
circonstances de ces deux dames
semblent bien différentes.
Le moment est aujourd'hui à la
poursuite des recherches et au
recueillement.
Viennent aussi les inquiétudes
pour les personnes qui se
retrouvent démunies et hors de
leur logement.
Madame la Première ministre,
qu'est-ce que le gouvernement
compte mettre en place pour aider
les personnes touchées par ce
terrible événement?
Pouvez-vous nous indiquer quelles
aides seront débloquées pour les
familles des victimes et pour
aider au relogement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup, mon cher collègue.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Klein, ministre délégué chargé de
la Ville et du Logement.
- Olivier Klein: Mesdames et
messieurs les députés, monsieur le
député Manuel Bompard, à mon tour,
je veux exprimer mes condoléances
et celles du gouvernement aux
familles des victimes, mon soutien
tout entier aux personnes qui sont
encore délogées et je voudrais
remercier l'ensemble des
parlementaires d'avoir été
présents aux côtés de Gérald
Darmanin dimanche et à mes côtés
hier pour écouter les informations
des marins-pompiers de Marseille.
Je veux aussi, bien évidemment,
saluer le magnifique travail
réalisé par les marins-pompiers de
Marseille depuis les premières
heures de ce terrible drame.
Comme vous l'avez fait, monsieur
le député, je voudrais saluer
aussi le travail des forces de
police municipale et nationale qui
sont elles aussi présentes pour
assurer la sécurité de ce site.
Bien évidemment, le temps de
l'enquête a commencé.
Le temps des recherches des
victimes continue.
Comme vous avez pu le constater
hier, le travail conjoint entre la
municipalité, le maire de
Marseille, la métropole et les
services de l'Etat est constant
pour être présent aux côtés des
familles des victimes et aux côtés
des familles qui sont délogées.
200 personnes aujourd'hui n'ont
pas encore pu rejoindre leur
domicile.
Une cinquantaine ont dormi à
l'hôtel, avec sept enfants.
Le travail du relogement sera
notre priorité.
Le travail de l'accompagnement de
ces familles sera notre priorité
aussi.
Le gouvernement sera aux côtés des
familles jusqu'à ce que chacun ait
pu regagner un domicile ou un
autre.
Je continuerai à vous informer de
ce qui sera mis en place.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Sabrina Agresti-Roubache.
- Sabrina Agresti-Roubache: Dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche,
Marseille a été frappée par un
drame, une catastrophe.
J'ai une pensée émue pour toutes
les familles des victimes de cet
événement qui s'est déroulé rue de
Tivoli.
Je pense également aux 200
personnes qui ont pu être évacuées
avec la réactivité de nos
marins-pompiers.
Avec l'ensemble de nos collègues,
nous tenons à rendre hommage au
courage et au travail des
marins-pompiers, des forces de
secours, des services de l'Etat,
de la ville de Marseille et de la
métropole.
Notre ville est une des plus
anciennes villes de France.
Son urbanisme est le fruit de son
histoire.
Le centre-ville s'est toujours
reconstruit sur lui-même.
Il est caractérisé par une
cohabitation de signes
architecturaux de différentes
époques.
Ce drame nous oblige car la crise
du logement est une énorme
préoccupation des Français.
Il est déterminant.
Marseille est solidaire.
Elle a toujours su faire face à
elle saura faire face.
Au-delà des spécificités de notre
ville, le chantier du logement est
titanesque: rénovation urbaine,
redémarrage de la construction,
développement de l'offre de
logements sociaux, lutte contre
les marchands de sommeil ou encore
lutte contre les logements
insalubres.
Autant de défis auxquels nous
devons collectivement faire face.
Comment allier les exigences des
nouveaux enjeux de la politique de
la ville avec les spécificités
urbanistiques de Marseille?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu, ministre de la
Transition écologique et de la
Cohésion des territoires.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
députée,
je m'associe à l'hommage aux
victimes, aux proches et à
l'ensemble des forces de secours
qui sont intervenues.
Votre question est plus large,
elle interroge sur le niveau de
politique de logement dans notre
pays et sur la façon de
reconstruire la ville sur
elle-même.
Quels que soient les logements
neufs qui pourraient se construire
dans des secteurs qui ne sont pas
urbanisés, nous avons un enjeu.
Compte tenu de la planification
écologique, nous devons
reconstruire la ville sur
elle-même.
Marseille est emblématique à ce
niveau.
Elle concentre des enjeux de
friche et des enjeux de rénovation
urbaine.
Pour faire face, le gouvernement
est mobilisé autour de deux
piliers.
D'abord, sous l'autorité du
président de la République et en
liaison étroite avec Olivier Faure
et Olivier Klein, nous avons lancé
le chantier de la décentralisation
du logement.
Est-ce qu'il faut décider depuis
Paris des zones qui sont tendues
et de celles qui ne le sont pas?
Si nous ne redonnons pas davantage
de pouvoir au maire, nous aurons
des difficultés en ce qui concerne
la signature de permis de
construire.
Le deuxième levier, c'est le front
friches.
750 millions d'euros, 464.000 ha
de friches qui laisseront place à
95.000 logements.
4 millions de mètres carrés de
logements publics.
En pérennisant le front friches,
nous pourrons continuer à
accompagner les territoires.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Anna Pic,
pour le groupe socialiste.
- Anna Pic: Ma question s'adresse
à madame la Première ministre.
11 journées de mobilisation, des
millions de Français dans la rue,
pour la première fois pour
beaucoup d'entre eux, une
intersyndicale au grand complet
toujours aussi déterminée et
historiquement soudée, 66% de
Français opposés à votre réforme
et quasiment autant d'entre eux
favorables aux blocages.
Voici le bilan catastrophique de
votre gouvernement depuis que vous
avez fait le choix d'engager, quoi
qu'il en coûte, une réforme des
retraites aussi injuste et
injustifiée sur le fond que
brutale sur la forme.
La gronde sociale est historique.
Face à cela, on a un pouvoir
exécutif toujours aussi
inflexible.
Notre Constitution permet de
sortir de l'impasse démocratique
dans laquelle vous nous avez
enfermés en ayant recours au 49.1,
puis au 49.3.
En quelques semaines, vous avez
fait entrer le pays dans une crise
politique, sociale et démocratique
dont les Français se seraient bien
passés.
Vous accumulez les contrevérités,
notamment sur les 1200 euros et
sur le nombre de bénéficiaires.
Vos contrevérités enfoncent un peu
plus chaque jour le pays dans la
crise.
En lieu et place du mépris affiché
par le président de la République,
nous avons collectivement besoin
d'apaisement.
Madame la Première ministre, force
est de constater que vous avez vu
juste en appelant à une période de
tempérance.
Nous ne sommes pas encore en
convalescence.
La bonne prescription, c'est le
retrait.
Avec cette reconnaissance, vous
avez fait le premier pas et il ne
tient qu'à vous de faire le
deuxième et de faire en sorte que
cette erreur démocratique ne
devienne pas un échec fracturant
notre pacte social.
Allons-nous enfin vers
l'apaisement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Vous avez
évoqué plusieurs sujets, mais
permettez-moi de revenir sur trois
points.
Premièrement, le texte arrive à la
fin de son cheminement.
Vendredi, le Conseil
constitutionnel aura à rendre sa
décision, puisqu'il a été saisi
par un certain nombre de
parlementaires et par la Première
ministre.
Ce texte a fait l'objet de
nombreuses concertations.
Il a été concerté pendant quatre
mois.
Il a fait l'objet de 175 heures de
débats dans cet hémicycle comme au
Sénat.
Il a été voté à deux reprises par
le Sénat et validé par une
commission mixte paritaire
composée des représentants des
deux chambres.
Avec la Première ministre, nous
avons reçu l'intersyndicale pour
dire à la fois qu'il y a toujours
un désaccord sur la question de
l'âge, mais dire aussi qu'il y a
d'autres sujets sur lesquels nous
devrons travailler.
Lorsqu'ils seront prêts, la porte
de Matignon et la porte du
ministère du Travail seront
toujours ouvertes pour continuer à
avancer.
Vous dites que cette réforme ne
permet pas d'avancer, mais songez
simplement aux quelques débats que
nous avons eus.
Sur les 17 millions de retraités
actuels, 1,8 million vont voir
leur pension de retraite
revalorisée.
Vous considérez, mesdames et
messieurs de la NUPES, que 100
euros par mois, ce n'est rien.
Passez le périph et regardez la
réalité en face.
Vous dites que cette réforme
devrait être retirée.
La vérité, c'est que vous ne le
ferez croire à personne.
En 2010, je me suis opposé à la
réforme des retraites.
En 2013, nous avons allongé la
durée de cotisation.
Nous avons renforcé la réforme de
2010.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à monsieur Grégoire
de Fournas pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Grégoire de Fournas: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur Marc Fesneau,
ministre de l'Agriculture.
Monsieur le ministre, qui est
absent, la semaine dernière, les
céréaliers se sont indignés d'une
nouvelle décision totalement
incompréhensible de ne plus
permettre l'usage d'un insecticide
chargé de protéger les céréales.
Cette décision conduira la France
à ne plus pouvoir exporter près de
12 millions de tonnes de céréales,
avec un préjudice de 3,8 milliards
d'euros par an pour la balance
commerciale française.
Cette décision unique en Europe va
fermer à nos céréaliers des
marchés essentiels, provoquant des
tensions sur les prix et le
renforcement du pouvoir
alimentaire de la Russie,
notamment sur l'Afrique du nord.
Comment une décision aussi lourde
de conséquences a pu être prise
sans que vous ne soyez intervenus?
Vous êtes incapables de protéger
nos agriculteurs de normes
absurdes.
Votre propre administration
échappe à votre contrôle.
Les Français découvrent un
gouvernement en panne qui n'a
comme programme que consultations
et bavardages.
Ils se demandent quelle est
encore votre utilité à la tête du
gouvernement.
On ne peut gouverner sans assumer
des choix politiques courageux.
Quand allez-vous défendre nos
agriculteurs et les intérêts de la
France?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Olivier
Becht.
- Olivier Becht: Monsieur le
député de Fournas,
vous l'avez dit, l'autorité de
sécurité alimentaire souhaitait
interdire l'usage de la phosphine
sur les exportations de céréales.
Il n'y a aucune règle européenne
qui empêche l'utilisation de la
phosphine lorsque les céréales
sont à destination de
l'exportation lorsqu'un pays
importateur l'autorise lui-même.
Ces exportations sont
indispensables à la sécurité
sanitaire de certains pays
importateurs comme l'Algérie, le
Maroc, le Sénégal et la Côte
d'Ivoire.
Nous avons donc besoin aujourd'hui
que la phosphine soit autorisée
pour les produits à l'exportation.
C'est ce qui sera fait d'ici le 25
avril.
Nous cherchons le cadre juridique
clair qui permette de le faire.
Il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de souci
à se faire sur les exportations.
Celles-ci continueront.
C'est bon pour nos exportateurs,
c'est bon pour la sécurité
alimentaire de ces pays et c'est
bon également d'un point de vue
géopolitique.
Dans le contexte de la guerre
d'agression de la Russie en
Ukraine, cela va se faire pour le
bien de l'ensemble de ces pays.
- Grégoire de Fournas: Monsieur le
ministre, les betteraviers se
souviennent de votre impuissance
et de votre incapacité.
Nous vous demandons d'être le
ministère de l'Action.
Il vous reste 15 jours pour le
prouver.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
- Olivier Becht: Ce gouvernement
agira et nous vous le prouverons
d'ici le 25 avril.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Emmanuel Lacresse pour
le groupe Renaissance.
- Emmanuel Lacresse: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le ministre
des Transports, j'associe à ma
question un collègue de Marseille.
Le président de la République, le
27 novembre, s'est fixé comme
objectif de créer de véritables
RER métropolitains régionaux.
Une première liste a été remise.
Cet objectif soulève une immense
attente.
Ma question porte sur
l'utilisation des 100 milliards
qui ont été annoncés par madame la
Première ministre.
Il faut, au-delà de la poursuite
des projets de lignes de trains
nouvelles, de la relance des
trains de nuit.
Lorsque vous êtes venu à Nancy
récemment, vous avez fait état des
problèmes rencontrés à Strasbourg,
mais cela ne doit pas nous
décourager.
Vous avez évoqué l'idée de fournir
en Lorraine un véritable RER du
sillon lorrain qui irait du
Luxembourg jusqu'à Nancy.
Nous en portons la promesse.
La question porte sur la méthode
que vous comptez adopter.
Le grand chantier sera-t-il mené
par l'Etat ou, comme en
Ile-de-France, par des sociétés
dédiées?
Comment y seront associés les
membres de l'exécutif?
Comment offrir aux étudiants et
aux familles des parcours
décarbonés complets?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Clément Beaune,
ministre chargé des Transports.
- Clément Beaune: Monsieur le
député Emmanuel Lacresse,
l'ambition des RER métropolitains
est une immense ambition pour
notre pays, une immense ambition
pour développer le transport
public, pour faire face à la
transition écologique et pour
réduire notre dépendance à la
voiture.
Beaucoup de nos compatriotes
voudraient pouvoir trouver des
transports publics qui leur
permettent de faire leurs trajets
entre le domicile et le travail,
mais qui ne le peuvent pas
aujourd'hui.
C'est l'ambition que la Première
ministre a déclinée en présentant
un plan pour les transports de 10
à 15 métropoles françaises.
Il ne s'agit pas seulement de RER,
ni seulement de RER
métropolitains.
Il faudra les adapter à chaque
territoire concerné.
Il pourrait y avoir des logiques
au cas par cas.
Il ne s'agit pas d'un projet pour
les centres-villes seulement, mais
justement pour celles et ceux qui
sont à 40 km de nos centres-villes
et qui n'ont aujourd'hui aucune
autre option de transport public
pour rejoindre l'autre bout de
leur métropole.
A Nancy, en particulier, dans le
sillon lorrain, un projet a déjà
été travaillé.
Des travaux ont été menés.
Je sais à quel point vous y êtes
attentif.
Nous allons devoir changer de
méthode.
Dans les 100 milliards d'euros, il
y aura des crédits pour les RER
métropolitains, mais nous ne
devons exclure aucune piste.
Les sociétés de projets sont un
outil important.
Je sais que des travaux sont déjà
à l'oeuvre.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Marie
Pochon pour le groupe écologiste.
- Marie Pochon: Cette question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de l'Agriculture.
Chaque génération se voit vouée à
refaire le monde.
La mienne sait qu'elle ne le
refera pas, mais sa tâche est
peut-être encore plus grande.
Elle consiste à empêcher que le
monde se défasse, comme le disait
Albert Camus.
Pourtant, ces derniers mois, c'est
à l'écologie que certains s'en
prennent.
Nous, militants de l'écologie,
sommes abasourdis et inquiets.
Dans le Lot-et-Garonne, dans les
Deux-Sèvres, partout, des
incendies de fermes, des
agressions pleuvent.
Entre autres accusations
d'écoterrorisme, les invectives
règnent.
Le 18 novembre, un habitant a été
roué de coups devant chez lui.
Le 30 janvier, un agriculteur a
été cagoulé, ficelé et menacé par
trois hommes qui en avaient "marre
de voir sa gueule à la télé".
A Sainte-Soline, un cap a été
franchi.
Quelle est la prochaine étape?
Attendez-vous des morts?
En désignant les écologistes comme
vos ennemis, vous affirmez devant
tous les Français qu'il est normal
de menacer des militants et même
des fonctionnaires, comme lors
d'un incendie à Brest.
Comment s'étonner alors que
beaucoup ne croient plus au
dialogue?
Alors que certains agressent les
écologistes,
êtes-vous du côté de ces mafieux
qui détruisent nos terres?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Madame la
députée, j'excuse Marc Fesneau.
Le sujet, ce n'est pas d'être d'un
côté ou de l'autre.
Le sujet, c'est d'être de ceux qui
dénoncent toutes les violences et
toutes les intimidations, ceux qui
préfèrent les insultes plutôt que
le processus démocratique.
Le simple fait que vous réagissiez
pendant que je réponds témoigne du
caractère trouble que vous avez
par rapport à ces questions.
Vous devriez acquiescer.
Il n'y a pas d'un côté des
violences qui seraient légitimes
et de l'autre, des violences qui
seraient illégitimes.
La question de l'eau, elle est
cruciale.
Est-ce qu'on peut, sur ce sujet,
éviter de se faire la guerre et
mesurer en face qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre solution que la sobriété?
Tous ceux qui prétendent hurler
proposent des réponses binaires.
Vous vous faites les complices de
ceux qui s'adonnent à des
comportements écervelés.
S'il vous plaît, est-ce que
là-dessus, on est capables de
trouver des consensus républicains
au lieu de se jeter des anathèmes
les uns aux autres?
Le réchauffement climatique est
une réalité non pas politique,
mais naturelle.
Rejoignez-nous sur les solutions.
Regardons au cas par cas au niveau
des territoires ce que nous
pouvons mettre en oeuvre.
Entrez dans le pragmatisme et dans
les solutions!
C'est à ce prix-là qu'on
réconciliera nos citoyens avec
l'écologie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Naegelen.
- Christophe Naegelen: Merci.
La loi Rist est entrée en vigueur
le 3 avril dernier.
Elle plafonne le salaire des
médecins intérimaires.
On doit en saluer l'objectif, tout
d'abord, par justice pour les
praticiens hospitaliers
titulaires, qui sont bien moins
rémunérés et pourtant bien plus
investis dans l'hôpital publique.
Mais aussi pour empêcher la
pratique d'enchères qui est
indécente.
Malheureusement, cette mise en
place amène des fermetures de lits
et de services, comme par exemple
chez moi.
Ce n'est qu'un exemple parmi tant
d'autres.
Je pense que tous nos collègues
sont concernés.
Cela entraîne un problème pour les
usagers et aussi pour
l'organisation interne à
l'hôpital, avec des infirmières et
des soignantes qui se retrouvent
affectées dans d'autres services
et avec des conditions de travail
encore plus dégradées.
Madame la Première ministre, mes
questions seront donc très
simples.
Quel est l'état de la situation
actuelle?
Combien de médecins qui, du fait
du plafonnement, se sont
désengagés de l'hôpital public?
Quelles mesures envisagez-vous?
Le changement du numerus clausus
n'a pas changé grand-chose.
Madame la Première ministre, que
prévoyez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la Première
ministre.
- Elisabeth Borne: Merci.
Comme vous, je connais les
difficultés et les craintes de nos
citoyens pour leur accès à la
santé et aux soins.
Nous en avons parlé à plusieurs
reprises et je connais votre
engagement sur ces questions.
Avec mon gouvernement, nous sommes
déterminés à bâtir des solutions
adaptées à chaque territoire,
déterminés à garantir à chacun,
partout en France, l'accès aux
soins dont il a besoin.
C'est précisément pour porter
cette volonté et cette conviction
que j'ai été vendredi dernier en
Aveyron, avec les ministres
François Braun et Agnès Firmin Le
Bodo, auprès des professionnels de
santé et des élus locaux.
Monsieur le président, vous
m'interrogez sur quelques points
précis.
D'abord, sur l'intérim, de
nouvelles règles ont fait l'objet
de larges concertations et elles
sont essentielles pour le bon
fonctionnement de notre hôpital.
Un très gros travail
d'anticipation a été mené par les
ministres, en lien avec les
agences régionales de santé.
Nous suivons attentivement la
situation, notamment de certaines
maternités.
Des organisations territoriales
sont mises en place et des
solutions recherchées, en lien
permanent avec les élus locaux.
Notre objectif est clair: limiter
au maximum l'impact sur les
services qui faisaient beaucoup
appel à l'intérim, mais tenir
aussi, sur ce principe de
plafonnement, pour assainir des
pratiques déloyales et
décourageantes pour les praticiens
hospitaliers.
Ensuite, sur la formation, la fin
du numerus clausus était une
décision attendue.
Si elle avait été prise plus tôt,
nous n'en serions pas là.
Je souhaiterais que nous
travaillions à la complémentarité
des professions de santé.
Nous souhaitons gagner du temps
médical.
Je ne vais pas détailler toutes
les mesures, mais je pourrais
citer la création de 10.000 postes
d'assistants médicaux d'ici fin
2024, le développement des maisons
de santé.
Elles étaient 1000 en 2017.
Elles sont aujourd'hui 2250.
Je pense aussi à ce que peuvent
accomplir les infirmiers.
Nous expérimentons la délivrance
de certificats de décès, ce qui
était très attendu par les maires.
Bien sûr, nous devons aller plus
loin, construire avec les
professionnels de santé et les
élus locaux des solutions adaptées
à chaque territoire.
Ce week-end, un décret a été
publié, qui permet d'adapter les
règles aux besoins spécifiques des
territoires.
Nous souhaitons apporter des
réponses aux jeunes soignants,
notamment en termes de logement.
L'accès aux soins est une priorité
des Français.
Avec les soignants, avec les élus,
nous sommes déterminés à trouver
des solutions adaptées à chaque
territoire.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Raquel
Garrido.
- Raquel Garrido: Madame la
Première ministre, selon vous, la
France est convalescente.
Mais elle ne l'est pas, madame: la
France est malade.
Elle est malade de voir ses grands
principes démocratiques et sociaux
foulés aux pieds.
C'est votre loi retraite qui
blesse la France, dont la
température est de 49.3.
C'est votre 49.3 du 16 mars qui a
provoqué un mal si intense que la
mobilisation s'est vue renouvelée.
Les Français sont malades de vous
voir parler de "cheminement
démocratique", alors que depuis le
début, vous refusez de justifier
en droit l'usage du 49.3.
Ce vendredi, le Conseil
constitutionnel va rendre son
avis.
S'il vous censure, il assume un
rôle politique qui n'est pas le
sien.
S'il ne vous censure pas, il
renonce à défendre la Constitution
dont il a la garde et affaiblit
alors la Ve République, qui se
porte déjà très mal.
Si vous assumiez, madame, votre
responsabilité et deveniez
l'antidote à la maladie que vous
avez vous-même générée, le pays ne
s'en porterait-il pas mieux?
Retirez la loi!
C'est encore le message qui sera
porté en masse dans les
manifestations de ce jeudi 13
avril.
La décision du Conseil
constitutionnel n'est pas soumise
à des recours.
Quelle que soit la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel, il n'y
aura pas de guérison sans retrait
de la loi!
L'aspiration démocratique est
profonde et puissante.
Les Français tiennent de cette
Constitution certains droits
fondamentaux, dont celui de faire
grève et de manifester.
Ils sont en droit de combattre la
promulgation de votre loi
retraite.
Leur détermination est intacte.
Retirez la loi!
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Olivier Dussopt.
- Olivier Dussopt: Merci.
Madame la députée, je dois avouer
que votre question me laisse
perplexe.
J'ai la grande chance de siéger
dans cet hémicycle depuis 2007.
Depuis 2007, je n'ai jamais
entendu un parlementaire préjuger
comme vous l'avez fait d'une
décision du Conseil
constitutionnel, jamais.
Je n'ai jamais vu ni entendu un
parlementaire remettre en cause
par avance la légitimité d'une
décision.
La réalité, c'est que vous
cherchez, comme depuis le début du
débat sur les retraites, à
délégitimer les institutions, à
abîmer la parole du Parlement, à
abîmer l'action publique, à abîmer
nos institutions et la République.
Par vos propos, par votre volonté
de remettre en cause par avance
une décision au cas où elle vous
serait défavorable, vous voulez
déjà la discréditer.
Ce n'est pas très responsable.
C'est raconter des sottises aux
Français.
Vous racontez des sottises sur une
réforme nécessaire et que vous
considérez comme n'étant pas
nécessaire.
Vous avez voulu filer la métaphore
médicale.
J'ai repensé au "Malade
imaginaire".
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Latombe.
- Philippe Latombe: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Fonction publique.
L'an dernier, dans une étude, le
Conseil d'Etat a encouragé
vivement les pouvoirs publics à
intégrer l'IA comme un paramètre
majeur des politiques publiques.
Il s'agissait de la mettre au
service de nos concitoyens.
Ce travail, excellent au
demeurant, a incité les pouvoirs
publics à s'approprier ce que l'on
peut considérer comme un
bouleversement majeur.
Depuis quelques mois, ChatGPT est
présent dans les médias, et même
dans cette Assemblée.
Face à la montée de ces
technologies et au caractère
inéluctable de leurs usages, il
est impératif que l'Etat s'en
saisisse.
Concernant l'action publique, l'IA
pourrait améliorer nos usages.
Pouvez-vous nous donner les
grandes lignes de notre feuille de
route?
Comment l'administration
envisage-t-elle de s'approprier ce
nouvel outil?
Le gouvernement envisage-t-il de
renforcer ses prérogatives et ses
effectifs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Stanislas Guerini.
- Stanislas Guerini: Merci.
Oui, l'année 2022 a été marquée
par la percée décisive des modèles
d'intelligence artificielle, avec
de grandes conséquences et de
grands bouleversements en matière
d'emplois, d'emplois publics, en
matière de données personnelles,
en matière de transformation de
l'emploi ou encore en matière de
souveraineté.
Oui, vous avez raison, ce sont
autant de bonnes raisons pour que
l'Etat s'empare de ce sujet, ne le
subisse pas et réfléchisse à
l'impact de ces technologies sur
nos organisations, en construisant
un cadre.
Il faut identifier des cas
d'usage.
Avec Jean-Noël Barrot, dans les
prochaines semaines, nous allons
annoncer une série
d'expérimentations très concrètes,
qui pourront aller de la réponse
aux usagers à la simplification
des démarches administratives, en
passant par la codification
normative.
Nous n'excluons aucun sujet.
Le deuxième enjeu est de
développer nos propres outils.
Vous avez mentionné ChatGPT.
C'est la solution la plus connue
pour ses performances
spectaculaires, mais ce n'est pas
la seule.
Nous avons des alternatives de
logiciels libres, européennes,
françaises, et nous devons
capitaliser sur ces alternatives
pour nourrir la stratégie
française en matière
d'intelligence artificielle, qui
est déjà bien engagée.
Je veux aussi mentionner un
troisième enjeu, qui est celui de
l'accompagnement de nos agents à
l'utilisation de ces outils.
Là encore, il ne faut pas subir,
mais il faut anticiper la
transformation des métiers, les
besoins en formation, pour ne
jamais opposer la numérisation et
l'humanisation des services
publics.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à José Gonzalez.
- José Gonzalez: Merci.
Ma question pourrait s'adresser à
monsieur le ministre des Armées.
La LPM 2024-2030 nous laissait
espérer une autonomie stratégique,
espoir de courte durée.
L'entreprise en charge va être
rachetée par une société
américaine.
Vos gouvernements n'en sont pas à
leur première crise industrielle.
La liste des fleurons nationaux
sacrifiés sur l'autel de
l'attractivité est longue.
Il faut expliquer aux Français qui
nous écoutent les conséquences
d'un rachat américain.
Nos sous-marins auront toujours
besoin de robinets.
Deux solutions s'offrent alors à
nous.
Se résigner à acheter américain en
prenant le risque de se plier à
leurs réglementations agressives
ne serait pas dans notre intérêt.
Nous considérons que la France
doit se défendre par elle-même et
pour elle-même.
La souveraineté de notre Défense
nationale doit être à la base de
nos raisonnements.
Des solutions existent, par
ailleurs.
On pourrait utiliser le décret
Montebourg.
A long terme, il nous faudra
renouer avec une politique de
défense visionnaire.
Marine Le Pen a proposé la mise en
place d'un fonds souverain pour
protéger nos entreprises
d'éventuelles prédations
étrangères.
S'affirmer en tant que ministre
des Armées, c'est aussi faire face
aux commissaires-priseurs des
intérêts nationaux à Bercy ou à
Matignon.
Comptez-vous enfin agir pour les
intérêts de la France en bloquant
ce rachat?
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Olivia Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
Monsieur le député Gonzalez, je ne
vais pas vous refaire la liste de
cet important robinetier
français, qui intervient
principalement dans la fabrication
des robinets nucléaires.
Il est actuellement détenu par une
entreprise canadienne.
La famille de cette entreprise a
communiqué récemment sur les
discussions qui sont poussées avec
un autre grand producteur de
robinets américain.
Un accord de rachat par les
Américains pourrait avoir lieu
d'ici l'été.
Le temps est important.
Je veux dire par là que rien n'est
fait.
Bien sûr, nous sommes
particulièrement vigilants.
Les Etats-Unis ont une
réglementation très attentive.
Cela pourrait menacer la
confidentialité des informations
relatives aux technologies
développées.
Cette opération va être soumise à
contrôle.
Bien sûr, le ministre de
l'Economie, avec le ministre des
Armées et le ministre de
l'Energie, va statuer sur les
risques d'un tel rachat.
Le retour à l'industrie, il y a
ceux qui en parlent et il y a ceux
qui le font.
Depuis 2017...
Je sais que les chiffres, vous ne
les aimez pas.
Depuis 2017, il y avait 30%
d'investissements industriels en
plus dans ce pays grâce à la
politique menée par la majorité et
le gouvernement.
Oui, nous avons inversé la
tendance, même si ça ne fait pas
vos affaires.
Depuis le décret Arnaud
Montebourg...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Félicie Gérard.
- Félicie Gérard: Merci.
En 2022, la France a exporté près
de 30 Mt de céréales.
Elle se place au septième rang
mondial des exportateurs de
céréales brutes.
La France s'impose comme le
premier producteur européen de
céréales et le premier exportateur
de blé de l'Union Européenne.
A partir du 25 avril, la France ne
pourra plus exporter sa production
céréalière en dehors de l'Europe.
Cette date marque l'interdiction
de l'utilisation de phosphine pour
traiter les cargaisons de céréales
dans les bateaux.
Les céréaliers n'ont pas d'autre
choix de molécule pour garantir la
sécurité des céréales.
Cette nouvelle restriction va
avoir de nombreuses conséquences.
L'utilisation de ce produit est
obligatoire dans de nombreux pays
clients de l'Hexagone pour pouvoir
débarquer la marchandise.
C'est notamment le cas de
l'Afrique du Nord.
En conséquence, l'export des
céréales françaises sera bloqué.
Les autres pays européens
exportateurs vont pouvoir
continuer à utiliser la molécule
de phosphine.
Cela va mettre la France dans une
position de désavantage fort.
La décision de l'Anses porte
atteinte grave à l'export d'une
filière stratégique pour la
France.
Ainsi, comment le gouvernement
compte-t-il réagir face à cette
décision?
Il ne faut pas laisser les
céréaliers sans solution.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Marc Fesneau.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci.
Votre question vient prolonger
celles qui ont été posées avant
mon arrivée.
La France va continuer d'exporter
des céréales à l'attention des
pays tiers.
Elle va le faire, y compris après
le 25 avril.
Elle le fait dans le cadre du
droit européen.
Cela permet de déroger à
l'interdiction qui est faite
d'utiliser de tels produits.
Les pays d'importation réclament
la présence de cette molécule,
donc nous la mettons dans les
céréales.
Il faudra faire en sorte que la
sécurité sanitaire et la sécurité
alimentaire puissent exister en
Europe et dans le monde.
L'Allemagne le fait pour
l'Algérie, la Bulgarie le fait
pour l'Algérie, la Roumanie l'a
fait pour la Côte d'Ivoire.
Il n'y a pas de raison que nous y
dérogions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Jean-Marc Tellier.
- Jean-Marc Tellier: Madame la
présidente, monsieur le ministre
Bruno Le Maire, les prix flambent
et la situation devient
insupportable pour de nombreux
Français.
Ils sont contraints de débourser
de plus en plus pour subvenir à
leurs besoins vitaux, comme
l'énergie, les carburants, et
surtout la nourriture.
Des millions de Français ont faim
et doivent faire des sacrifices et
des choix difficiles pour
simplement boucler leurs fins de
mois.
Ils font les courses, la
calculatrice à la main.
4 Français sur 10 déclarent sauter
un repas.
Les bailleurs sociaux ont constaté
une augmentation des impayés de
10%.
Les pâtes deviennent du caviar.
Même les associations caritatives
ont du mal à se fournir en
aliments de base.
Alors, dans ce contexte, comment
peut-on accepter que quelques-uns
s'enrichissent indûment pendant
que la majorité de nos concitoyens
doit se serrer la ceinture?
Le fossé économique entre les plus
riches et les travailleurs est
gigantesque.
C'est une véritable injustice
sociale et économique qui est en
train de se jouer sous nos yeux.
Nos collectivités et nos CCAS sont
en première ligne.
Aujourd'hui, ils se battent pour
le droit de manger, alors
qu'avant, ils se battaient pour le
droit aux vacances, à la culture
et à l'éducation.
Monsieur le ministre, la solution
ne se trouve pas dans les mains
des grands industriels et des
grands distributeurs, à leur bon
vouloir.
Les Français ne veulent pas
l'aumône.
Ils veulent vivre de leur travail.
Ils ne veulent ni chèques
alimentaires, ni paniers
anti-inflation.
Quand allez-vous, avec votre
gouvernement, comprendre que la
solution, c'est l'augmentation
générale des salaires et des
pensions?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Merci.
Vous comprendrez, monsieur le
député Tellier, que je me permette
de vous répondre au nom de Bruno
Le Maire, qui est actuellement en
déplacement.
Que ce soit difficile pour un
certain nombre de nos
compatriotes, je ne vais pas le
nier.
Vous avez parlé de l'énergie, du
transport et de l'alimentation,
dans cet ordre.
Voilà exactement les trois pôles
de dépenses les plus importants
des ménages.
C'est bien pour cela que, depuis
l'été 2021, nous avons mis en
place le bouclier tarifaire, 110
milliards d'euros depuis le mois
d'août 2021.
Le bouclier tarifaire représente
environ 250 euros par mois
d'économie par ménage.
Nous avons mis en place
l'indemnité carburant, destinée
aux travailleurs, mais aussi
revalorisé l'ensemble des minima
sociaux et les retraites.
Nous avons mis en place l'aide
exceptionnelle de rentrée.
Nous avons supprimé des impôts,
dont la redevance
audiovisuelle.
C'est inédit.
Vous dites que cela ne sert à
rien, mais c'est inédit.
J'aurai l'immense loisir de
communiquer, dans les prochains
jours, sur les premiers bilans de
ces paniers anti-inflation et des
trimestres anti-inflation, ce qui
démontre que les prix commencent à
stagner et, pour certains, à
baisser.
Je veux aussi vous dire que, pour
ce qui est de demander aux
industriels de s'engager à une
nouvelle négociation parce que les
matières premières baissent, c'est
chose faite.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Paul Molac.
- Paul Molac: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à la
ministre de la Transition
écologique.
Depuis janvier 2022,
l'installation de chaudières à gaz
est interdite.
Cela va s'appliquer aussi aux
habitats collectifs à partir de
2025.
La filière s'inquiète.
Les discussions laissent à penser
que les chaudières au gaz
pourraient être purement et
simplement prohibées partout.
Cette interdiction aurait des
conséquences importantes.
Ces chaudières seront remplacées
par des pompes à chaleur, qui
coûtent plus cher et dont les
principaux composants viennent
d'Asie.
Cela va aussi entraîner une
augmentation de la consommation en
électricité.
Dans le contexte actuel de pénurie
de production d'électricité, cela
peut susciter quelques
inquiétudes.
De plus, de nombreux agriculteurs
ont investi dans la méthanisation,
dont la production de gaz vert est
directement injectée dans nos
réseaux.
Ces gaz verts font désormais
partie intégrante de l'économie de
nos territoires.
Ils permettent de décarboner la
filière gaz et de sortir de notre
dépendance au gaz russe.
Ce n'est pas le moment de mettre
fin à cette filière aux retombées
positives.
Je vais vous poser quelques
questions simples.
Avez-vous pour but d'interdire le
renouvellement des chaudières à
gaz et la prohibition du chauffage
au gaz?
Pouvez-vous nous assurer que la
production d'électricité sera en
capacité de répondre à
l'électrification massive du
secteur du chauffage et que le gaz
vert ne sera pas abandonné
purement et simplement?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Olivier Klein.
- Olivier Klein: Merci.
Permettez-moi d'excuser Agnès
Pannier-Runacher de son absence.
Vous le savez, l'ambition du
président est claire: nous devons
être le premier grand pays
industriel à se libérer de sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles
et atteindre la neutralité carbone
d'ici 2050.
C'est un objectif ambitieux mais
nécessaire pour nos concitoyens et
aussi pour la planète.
Pour cela, sous l'égide de la
Première ministre, nous
travaillons à décliner cette
ambition secteur par secteur, pour
atteindre cette neutralité
carbone.
Concernant le chauffage à gaz, qui
est l'objet de votre question, la
réglementation environnementale
impose, depuis le 1er janvier, une
part importante d'énergie
décarbonée pour le chauffage et la
production de l'eau chaude
sanitaire, pour les logements
neufs.
Cette première échéance s'est
imposée aux maisons individuelles
et s'étend progressivement à
l'habitat collectif et dans les
bâtiments tertiaires.
C'est un objectif nécessaire.
L'objectif qui est le nôtre est de
produire l'énergie la plus
décarbonée possible.
Il n'y a pas, à ce jour,
d'objectif d'interdiction de la
production de chauffage et d'eau
chaude sanitaire dans le logement
ancien.
C'est un travail que nous devons
mener collectivement avec
l'ensemble des acteurs et des
fournisseurs.
Je vous remercie.
- Paul Molac: Merci.
J'enregistre la réponse.
Le gaz vert peut être utilisé à
autre chose, en particulier à la
mobilité.
A un moment donné, il faut bien
regarder où on va.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à Patrice Perrot.
- Patrice Perrot: Ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre
de la Transition écologique et de
la Cohésion des territoires.
En tant que rapporteur de la
mission d'information de la
commission des affaires
économiques sur la gestion de
l'eau, je tiens à nouveau à saluer
les annonces qui ont été faites
par le président de la République
dans ce cadre le 30 mars dernier.
Ce plan est ambitieux.
Il comprend des mesures pour
protéger les ressources, garantir
un accès équitable à cette eau
potable et à lutter contre les
pollutions de l'eau.
Je souhaiterais, monsieur le
ministre, vous entendre sur
l'ensemble des moyens financiers
qui vont être mobilisés dans le
cadre de ce plan, sur les actions
qui sont menées dans la lutte
contre la surexploitation de
certaines nappes phréatiques, sur
la préservation des milieux en
termes de biodiversité et sur
l'accès à l'eau potable dans sa
grande globalité, notamment dans
les zones rurales.
Comment envisagez-vous de
travailler avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes, que ce soit les
parlementaires ou les
collectivités locales, pour que
nous réussissions cet enjeu qui
concerne le quotidien de nos
concitoyens, mais aussi notre
souveraineté alimentaire et
agricole?
Enfin, quels sont tous les
partenariats publics et privés qui
pourraient être mis en oeuvre pour
réussir à relever ce défi?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Monsieur le
député Perrot, d'abord, vous avez
cité le rapport en question sur la
gestion de l'eau
et je tiens à saluer tous ceux qui
y ont participé.
Vous avez, dans le cadre de cette
mission, beaucoup travaillé.
Le plan qui a été présenté au
président de la République, c'est
d'abord le retour d'expérience de
l'été dernier, la suite des
rapports de la Cour des comptes et
des rapports parlementaires, y
compris celui de juin 2018, qui
étaient complets.
On a essayé de déterminer les
niveaux financiers et les axes qui
étaient nécessaires pour optimiser
la ressource, organiser la
sobriété, renforcer la
gouvernance, améliorer la qualité
et faire en sorte de prévoir les
moyens.
L'eau, dans notre pays, c'est 20
milliards d'euros de dépenses
annuelles.
Les différents rapports, y compris
les rapports issus du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale, le retour
des acteurs de terrain nous dit
qu'il faut entre 5 et 6 milliards
d'euros par an supplémentaires
pour lutter contre les fuites,
pour proposer des systèmes
d'irrigation et pour organiser une
solution hydraulique agricole qui
permette de résoudre la question
de la sobriété avec les besoins de
la transition agricole.
Pour faire ça, nous appliquons le
modèle de ce qui existe
aujourd'hui.
Un peu plus de 2 milliards d'euros
sont à disposition de l'agence de
l'eau.
Nous avons besoin de 5 à 6
milliards supplémentaires.
Un contrôle parlementaire est
nécessaire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie, monsieur le ministre.
La parole est à madame Isabelle
Périgault pour le groupe Les
Républicains.
- Isabelle Périgault: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le ministre de la Santé.
Sans bruit, ils se lèvent chaque
matin avec pour seule boussole
l'envie de prendre soin des
autres.
Quand ils sont déçus du mépris et
de l'ignorance dont votre
gouvernement fait preuve à leur
égard, ils ne sont pas les
premiers à crier haut et fort
leurs revendications.
Cette fois-ci, c'en est trop.
L'exaspération des infirmiers
libéraux est en effet longtemps
restée silencieuse.
Pourtant, la colère gronde.
Depuis 2019, avec l'avenant qui
les contraint à éviter les prises
en charges lourdes car ces
dernières sont moins bien
rémunérées, leur forfait résulte
d'un algorithme qui classe les
patients en trois niveaux.
Cette situation est un supplice
pour eux.
Elle entraîne une dégradation
évidente de la prise en charge des
patients.
La loi de financement de la
Sécurité sociale 2023 a été pour
eux le coup de grâce.
L'article
102 les oblige, en cas
d'irrégularités, à être redevables
d'un indu à l'Assurance maladie.
L'amalgame qui est fait avec les
fraudeurs les blesse.
60 professionnels sur 100
envisagent d'abandonner leur
métier dans les 5 ans à venir.
Quand allez-vous répondre à leur
situation?
Ils souhaitent une revalorisation
de leur nomenclature, une
compensation pérenne des prix du
carburant, la prise en compte de
la pénibilité de leur profession
et un plan pour reprendre en main
les soins en ville.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur François
Braun, ministre de la Santé et de
la Prévention.
- François Braun: Madame la
députée Isabelle Périgault, notre
système de santé marche sur ses
deux jambes, une jambe libérale et
une jambe hospitalière, et il est
hors de question d'en favoriser
une par rapport à l'autre.
Nos infirmiers libéraux sont des
éléments essentiels de la chaîne
des soins, de l'accès à la santé
dans nos territoires.
Ce sont même les seuls dans les
territoires les plus éloignés, en
tout cas les seuls qui vont au
plus près des patients isolés et
dépendants.
Bien entendu, nous devons
reconnaître au mieux leurs
compétences et le rôle qu'ils
jouent dans cette chaîne de soins.
Il y a trois leviers pour cela.
Le premier consiste à agir sur les
compétences de ces infirmiers et à
les faire évoluer.
Je me réjouis qu'un projet de loi
reconnaisse un rôle-clé des
infirmiers, notamment dans la
prise en charge des plaies
chroniques.
Nous avons maintenu la
reconnaissance des soins et la
possibilité pour les infirmiers
libéraux de participer aux gardes
de nuit.
Cela a été fait l'été dernier dans
les EHPAD.
Il y a d'autres mesures que je
vais lancer dans quelques jours et
qui répondent à des préoccupations
dans les territoires.
Au-delà de cela, nous faisons
évoluer les formations des
infirmiers.
Il y a également le bilan des
soins infirmiers mis en place en
2020.
Il a été augmenté en 2022.
Nous maintenons le financement des
frais kilométriques?
- Isabelle Périgault: Vous ne
répondez pas à ma question.
Les infirmiers libéraux demandent
de la considération et d'agir en
fonction de leur métier.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Nicolas Thierry pour le
groupe écologiste.
- Nicolas Thierry: Cette question
s'adresse au ministre de la Santé.
Jour après jour, les scandales
sanitaires sont révélés.
Dernière évaluation en date: un
tiers de l'eau potable distribuée
est largement contaminée par un
pesticide interdit depuis 2020.
On savait que ce pesticide avait
la capacité de polluer massivement
notre eau potable.
Comment se fait-il que cet
insecticide n'ait pas fait l'objet
d'une surveillance plus précoce de
l'Etat alors que les risques
étaient connus?
Les autorités le savaient depuis
très longtemps et n'ont rien fait.
Cette inaction révèle le
non-respect du principe de
précaution.
Aujourd'hui, le scandale continue.
Suite aux révélations de l'Anses,
le gouvernement s'est voulu
rassurant.
Il a déclaré que cet insecticide
ne présentait pas de risque
sanitaire.
En réalité, aucune recherche
probante sur la toxicité de ce
produit n'a été conduite.
Il n'existe donc aucune certitude
sur les effets sanitaires à long
terme d'une exposition répétée à
cet insecticide.
Une étude censée nous rassurer va
être menée par un géant de
l'agrochimie.
Cette étude ne nous apprendra rien
sur les effets à long terme.
Comment accepter que le pollueur
soit aussi le commanditaire de
cette étude?
On ne peut pas être juge et
partie.
La santé publique ne doit pas être
subordonnée aux intérêts des
multinationales de l'agrochimie.
Allez-vous demander l'application
du principe de précaution?
Le gouvernement va-t-il cesser
d'autoriser des pesticides dont on
sait qu'ils aggravent les risques
de la toxicité de l'eau potable?
Allez-vous défendre nos vies
plutôt que les lobbys?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame la ministre
déléguée chargée de l'Organisation
territoriale et des Professions de
santé.
- Agnès Firmin Le Bodo: L'eau est
notre bien le plus précieux.
Sous l'autorité du ministère de la
Santé et de la Prévention, la
Direction générale de la santé
fait régulièrement appel à des
agences d'expertise françaises
pour disposer de connaissances
sanitaires sur ces pesticides.
L'Anses a publié la semaine
dernière les principaux résultats
de la dernière campagne
exploratoire de mesures relatives
aux polluants émergeants dans
l'eau potable.
L'Anses met en évidence une
contamination des ressources en
eau.
Cette pollution représente-t-elle
un risque sanitaire?
A ce stade et à date, la campagne
exploratoire de l'Anses a mis en
évidence des concentrations
maximales de 2 µg par litre, la
valeur sanitaire transitoire
permettant de prévenir le risque
sanitaire étant de 3 microgrammes
par litre.
Plusieurs responsables de la
production et de la distribution
ont déjà intégré ces substances
dans leur plan de surveillance.
Le programme des agences
régionales de santé va intégrer le
contrôle sanitaire des eaux pour
rendre des résultats fiables.
Ces éléments permettent de
poursuivre le travail
d'amélioration de surveillance des
eaux afin d'apporter des mesures.
C'est un sujet que nous suivons de
près et avec une grande vigilance.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Philippe
Bolo pour le groupe démocrate.
- Philippe Bolo: Ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre
chargée des petites et des
moyennes entreprises.
L'industrie porte les emplois
d'aujourd'hui et de demain.
Elle est créatrice de richesses à
partager.
Les crises économique et sanitaire
provoquées par le Covid-19 et la
guerre en Ukraine ont conduit à
des impasses dans lesquelles notre
pays a plongé.
Lorsqu'une industrie en difficulté
risque de fermer ses portes, vous
pouvez vous en rendre compte.
On peut trouver une aide pour les
industries de transition
climatique.
Il convient de redynamiser la
France sur cette voie.
Il faut viser un projet
d'industrie conjuguant prospérité
et économie circulaire.
La France ne doit pas se laisser
distancer par les pays d'Europe ou
d'ailleurs dans le monde qui
s'engagent dans un tel virage.
Pourriez-vous nous préciser
comment le prochain projet de loi
sur l'industrie verte va permettre
à la France d'être au rendez-vous?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Olivia
Grégoire.
- Olivia Grégoire: Monsieur le
député Bolo, je vous prie de bien
vouloir excuser la double absence
de Bruno Le Maire et de Roland
Lescure, qui est aux Pays-Bas avec
le président de la République pour
y parler justement d'industrie.
En France, comme à
l'international, le gouvernement
est à la tâche pour soutenir notre
industrie et notamment
l'implantation de projets
industriels.
Hier, la France ne produisait
plus.
Aujourd'hui, elle produit de
nouveau.
La taxation du capital avait
conduit à l'appauvrissement du
pays.
La politique qui est conduite
depuis 2017, notamment sur le plan
fiscal, permet à la nation
française de redevenir enfin une
nation de production, une nation
industrielle, ce qui se traduit
dans les chiffres: dans notre
pays, nous créons plus d'emplois
industriels que nous n'en avions
créé les précédentes années.
Plus de 90.000 emplois industriels
ont été recréés en cinq ans.
Le solde de création de nouvelles
usines est positif.
Ca ne sert pas les intérêts de
tout le monde, puisque certains
font leur politique sur le malheur
d'un certain nombre de nos
circonscriptions, mais force est
de constater que les projets
industriels reviennent dans notre
pays et que les emplois
industriels sont recréés.
On doit aller plus loin.
C'est pourquoi Bruno Le Maire
portera, avec Roland Lescure, un
nouveau projet de loi industriel
qui sera débattu au Parlement à
l'été.
Il s'agit d'arriver à un consensus
et de redonner les moyens aux
acteurs économiques pour implanter
des industries vertes dans notre
pays en leur facilitant la tâche
et la vie.
Les technologies qui vont
s'imposer sont connues:
l'hydrogène, les panneaux
photovoltaïques, les pompes à
chaleur...
Le dérèglement climatique est
clairement le défi de ce début de
siècle.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
Madame Frédérique Meunier.
- Frédérique Meunier: Monsieur le
ministre des Transports, les
aéroports régionaux d'aménagement
du territoire traversent
aujourd'hui des zones de
turbulences.
Certains ont signé des obligations
de service public, comme c'est le
cas de l'aéroport de Brive, en
Corrèze.
L'Etat s'était engagé à hauteur de
50% de participation, soit 20
millions d'euros sur quatre ans.
Aujourd'hui, à l'issue de la
première année d'exploitation, il
n'a réellement participé qu'à
hauteur de 34% car les recettes
sont plafonnées aux recettes
réalisées et non aux recettes
prévisionnelles.
Il faut ajouter à cela une
explosion du coût du carburant et
de la taxe carbone, ce qui oblige
les compagnies à dénoncer les ESP
pour obtenir des financements
supplémentaires.
Dans nos territoires ruraux, ces
aéroports sont de véritables
outils d'attractivité économique,
touristique et d'aménagement du
territoire.
Les collectivités qui participent
au financement des aéroports sont
prises en otage entre le besoin
impérieux d'avoir une ligne vers
Paris et la situation financière
exposée précédemment.
Les Corréziens ne peuvent plus
compter sur le train
Paris-Brive-Toulouse,
systématiquement en retard et
mettant 45 minutes de plus
aujourd'hui qu'en 1970, d'où la
nécessité de l'avion pour espérer
un développement économique.
Monsieur le ministre, ma question
est double: quelle est aujourd'hui
la stratégie du gouvernement sur
les lignes d'aménagement du
territoire, notamment au regard
des conclusions des assises du
transport aérien organisées en
mars 2019 par Elisabeth Borne,
alors ministre des Transports?
Quelle stratégie allez-vous
adopter afin de limiter les coûts
inflationnistes pratiqués à ce
jour par les transporteurs?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à monsieur Clément Beaune.
- Clément Beaune: Madame la
députée, vous avez raison
d'insister sur la nécessité d'un
certain nombre de lignes
d'aménagement du territoire, y
compris des lignes aériennes.
Il y a une ligne essentielle qui
concerne directement votre
département, votre territoire et
la ville de Brive.
Sur cette ligne, nous
réinvestissons massivement depuis
18 mois avec un effort de
renouvellement intégral des rames
qui datent parfois de plus de 50
ans.
Nous modernisons le réseau par un
financement intégral de l'Etat
pour un total de plus de 2
milliards d'euros.
C'est notre priorité absolue.
Nous assumons d'avoir une
stratégie complémentaire.
Nous continuons donc à
subventionner des lignes
d'aménagement du territoire.
Ce sont des lignes que mon
ministère soutient chaque année
pour un total de 25 millions par
an.
En ce qui concerne Brive, nous
avons renouvelé l'année dernière
cette ligne et ses obligations de
service public.
Le mécanisme que vous avez décrit
est contributeur au déficit
d'exportation.
Nous continuerons.
Nous regardons comment nous
pouvons adapter un certain nombre
de soutiens pour tenir compte de
l'augmentation des coûts de
l'énergie.
Nous allons le faire de manière
responsable et en lien avec les
collectivités qui portent aussi
ses obligations, pour que le
surcoût soit assumé de manière
équitable entre les différents
financeurs.
Je suis prêt à regarder de nouveau
avec vous pour la ligne de Brive
ce que nous pouvons faire.
Nous avons une priorité:
réinvestir dans le réseau
ferroviaire, réinvestir dans nos
lignes de train et accompagner les
lignes d'aménagement du territoire
sur le plan aérien.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Michel
Guiniot pour le Rassemblement
National.
- Michel Guiniot: Madame la
Première ministre, le 30 mars
dernier, l'INSEE, dans le silence
médiatique, a publié son rapport
sur l'immigration illégale dont
les résultats viennent confirmer
les mises en garde depuis 50 ans,
d'abord du Front National, puis
ensuite du Rassemblement National.
Selon les chiffres de l'INSEE, en
50 ans, l'immigration africaine a
augmenté de 515%.
1 personne sur 10 est issue de
l'immigration africaine.
En 50 ans, l'immigration asiatique
a augmenté de 1170%.
La majeure partie de ces
populations immigrées ne vient pas
de pays en guerre.
En 2011, 1 résident sur 10 est un
immigré en France.
Où sont l'intégration et
l'assimilation?
Certains diront que la France a
toujours été une terre d'asile,
mais dans quelles proportions?
La France n'a jamais été
confrontée à une telle situation.
En 1911, 1 personne sur 36 était
immigrée.
Aujourd'hui, c'est 1 personne sur
10.
La population immigrée a été
multipliée par 10 tandis que la
population totale n'a même pas
doublé.
Tout cela, ce sont les chiffres du
rapport de l'INSEE.
L'exemple de l'Ile-de-France est
révélateur.
Près d'1 personne sur 5 est
immigrée.
20% à Paris, 21% dans le
Val-d'Oise, 22% dans le
Val-de-Marne.
Cette immigration déborde
aujourd'hui sur les départements
limitrophes, et en particulier sur
l'Oise.
Cette immigration a des
conséquences sociales et
économiques.
30% des immigrés, selon l'INSEE,
sont sans activité.
50% des titres de séjour délivrés
concernent une immigration
économique et familiale.
Chaque année, entre 150.000 et
200.000 nouveaux individus migrent
légalement en France, soit
l'équivalent d'une ville comme
Rennes.
50% des étrangers continuent de
pratiquer leur langue d'origine...
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à madame Sonia
Backès.
- Sonia Backès: Monsieur le
député, permettez-moi d'abord
d'excuser Gérald Darmanin, qui est
occupé à recevoir les acteurs du
dossier de la Nouvelle-Calédonie.
La France fait effectivement face
aujourd'hui à des flux migratoires
presque au niveau de ceux que nous
avons connus pendant la crise de
2015.
Regardez cette réalité en face
avec objectivité et mesure,
monsieur le député.
C'est la condition nécessaire pour
préparer notre pays aux défis qui
l'attendent.
Le gouvernement mobilise des
moyens sans précédent sur la lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière.
Je pourrais rappeler ici les
moyens déployés.
La plus grande fermeté s'applique
aux étrangers auteurs d'actes de
délinquance, de crimes ou de
délits.
Ils bafouent la tradition
d'accueil dont la République
s'honore.
Leur éloignement est notre
priorité.
En 2022, 2500 titres de séjour ont
été retirés pour cause de troubles
à l'ordre public.
3615 étrangers en situation
irrégulière ont été expulsés.
On retrouve cette même ambition de
fermeté dans le projet porté par
le ministère de l'Intérieur et le
ministère du Travail.
Ils veulent assouplir les
conditions d'expulsion des
étrangers en levant les
protections existantes.
Cette fermeté n'est pas attendue
seulement par les Français.
Elle est aussi demandée par les
étrangers qui ne veulent plus être
confondus avec ceux qui abîment
leur réputation et mettent à mal
leurs efforts d'intégration, et
c'est une fille d'immigrés qui
vous le dit.
Cette fermeté va de pair avec
l'amélioration de notre politique
d'asile et de nos dispositifs
d'intégration par la maîtrise du
français, le travail et le respect
de nos valeurs républicaines.
Pour une politique d'accueil plus
efficace et plus humaine, nous
assumons pleinement aujourd'hui de
vouloir accueillir moins pour
accueillir mieux.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à madame Farida
Amrani pour le groupe La France
Insoumise.
- Farida Amrani: Monsieur le
ministre de l'Economie, en
février, vous annonciez qu'il n'y
aurait pas de mois de mars rouge
et qu'il ne fallait pas faire peur
aux Français.
Au mois de mars, l'inflation des
prix des produits alimentaires a
dépassé pour la première fois les
15%.
On n'a jamais vu ça depuis 1980.
La hausse des prix alimentaires
affecte en premier lieu les
Français les plus pauvres.
Dans ma circonscription, les
étudiants de l'université font la
queue par centaines aux Restos du
Coeur pour se nourrir.
Dans les quartiers populaires de
Corbeil-Essonnes, certains ne
mangent qu'une seule fois par jour
pour garantir un repas le soir à
leurs enfants.
Certains retraités sont contraints
de voler au supermarché pour se
nourrir.
Aujourd'hui, une famille de deux
personnes dépense 521 euros par
mois au supermarché.
C'est quasiment 100 euros de plus
qu'il y a un an.
+25% pour le riz,
+22% pour le beurre.
Aujourd'hui, plus de 8 millions de
personnes ont recours à l'aide
alimentaire en France.
C'est votre bilan.
Vous le savez pertinemment.
La hausse des prix dans les
supermarchés est dopée par les
profits de l'industrie
agroalimentaire.
Les profits du secteur ont doublé,
passant de 3 à 6 milliards.
Vous refusez de voir la réalité en
face.
A la mise en place des repas à 1
euro pour les étudiants, vous
préférez la mise en place
d'antivols sur les sachets de
pâtes.
Quand allez-vous diminuer les
marges des multinationales qui
gonflent les prix?
Quand allez-vous mettre en place
le blocage des prix?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Jean-Christophe Combe.
- Jean-Christophe Combe: Madame la
députée Amrani, la lutte contre
l'inflation et ses conséquences
sur nos concitoyens est au coeur
des préoccupations de ce
gouvernement.
En effet, nous le savons, même si
l'inflation est moins forte en
France qu'ailleurs, elle frappe
plus durement les ménages avec les
revenus les plus modestes, les
personnes âgées, mais aussi ceux
qui vivent le plus loin des
villes.
Sur 12 mois, l'inflation a atteint
5,6%.
C'est heureusement moins
qu'ailleurs en Europe.
Nous le devons aux aides accordées
par l'Etat pour contenir la hausse
des prix de l'énergie.
Nous devions contenir la hausse de
l'inflation sur les ménages les
plus modestes.
Nous avons augmenté les minima
sociaux de plus de 4%.
A cela s'est ajoutée une
allocation exceptionnelle de
solidarité distribuée aux ménages
les plus modestes pour un montant
de 160 euros en moyenne.
Il y a eu aussi un chaque énergie
jusqu'à 200 euros par famille.
Nous avons renforcé les moyens des
associations de solidarité avec le
triplement des crédits de l'aide
alimentaire.
Cela nous a permis de débloquer
une aide de 10 millions d'euros en
urgence cet automne pour aider
dans l'urgence les étudiants.
Ma collègue Olivia Grégoire a fait
référence au trimestre
anti-inflation.
Je signale le programme Mieux
manger pour tous, dont le
déploiement est en cours.
60 millions d'euros seront dévolus
aux associations d'aide
humanitaire au niveau national.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
Madame Amrani?
- Farida Amrani: Pâtes, steaks
hachés, +2,46 euros en un an.
Les chiffres ne mentent pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: La parole est
à madame Laurence Heydel Grillere.
- Laurence Heydel Grillere: Merci.
Je reviens vers vous concernant
une autre spécialité française qui
fait le bonheur de nos voisins
européens et d'autres pays dans le
monde, mais qui nous a amenés à
perdre notre souveraineté
alimentaire.
Je veux évidemment parler de la
spécialité française de
surtransposition des normes
agricoles.
L'Anses a décidé d'interdire, à
partir du 25 avril, l'utilisation
d'un insecticide utilisé pour
l'exportation des céréales.
Dans une dizaine de jours, les
agriculteurs français ne vont plus
pouvoir exporter de céréales hors
de l'Union Européenne.
Ces exportations représentent 11,5
millions de tonnes de grains
divers.
Ce n'est pas le pire.
Dans le même temps, les Français
vont pouvoir continuer à importer
des céréales traitées avec cet
insecticide.
Cette situation interroge.
Elle pourrait prêter à sourire si
elle n'avait pas autant de
conséquences pour nos
agriculteurs.
Que l'Anses ne se pose pas la
question de l'existence d'un pass
sanitaire, de l'émergence de
solutions, de la pérennité de
l'exploitation, c'est une chose,
son métier est d'évaluer le risque
pour la santé, mais où est la
place du politique pour définir le
niveau de danger acceptable?
Nous ne pouvons pas laisser faire.
Nous ne pouvons pas être aussi
inactifs que les gouvernements de
droite et de gauche qui ont
désindustrialisé la France et
laissé mourir notre agriculture.
Nos ambitions pour la souveraineté
alimentaire, pour nos
agriculteurs, sont claires depuis
six ans.
Monsieur le ministre, ma question
est la suivante: comment garantir
la souveraineté alimentaire et
respecter les enjeux climatiques?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Marc
Fesneau, ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la Souveraineté alimentaire.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci.
Votre question me permettra de
compléter la première réponse que
j'ai faite sur le sujet de la
phosphine.
Je crois que j'aurai une autre
question, plus tard, sur le même
sujet.
Je veux rappeler que c'est bon de
lire le droit, sur ces sujets.
Nous sommes strictement dans la
disposition du deuxième paragraphe
du règlement 369-2005.
Il faut d'abord agir en droit, sur
ces questions.
On va produire cette dérogation.
Le deuxième sujet: le droit
européen, qui est clair.
Nous sommes dans une situation
particulière qui exige de
s'assurer de la sécurité
alimentaire de nos voisins.
C'est la responsabilité de la
France.
Nous allons nous conformer au
droit, à la politique et à la
géopolitique.
Merci.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Dominique
Potier.
- Dominique Potier: Merci.
Ma question va détonner, avec les
trois précédentes sur l'Anses.
Elle s'adresse à la Première
ministre.
Les dernières déclarations du
gouvernement nous ont pour le
moins paru confuses, au moment où
notre pays a besoin de se
rassembler dans la clarté.
Je vais rappeler le caractère
anachronique de la remise en cause
de la décision de l'Anses.
Elle est la réponse à une saisine
des ministères de l'Agriculture,
de la Santé et de l'Environnement,
le 17 mai 2021.
Il y a des alternatives qui
existent.
Sur le fond, il nous semble que
c'est une remise en cause de
l'article 13-13-1 de la loi
promulguée en 2015 et qui donne à
l'Anses les pouvoirs de déterminer
quand un produit doit être
autorisé ou pas.
Toute reprise en main politique
serait une fiction.
Elle reviendrait de fait à donner
les pleins pouvoirs à l'économie,
dans une vision paradoxale où les
bénéfices seraient pour
quelques-uns, et les risques pour
tous les autres.
Nous aimerions que vous puissiez
nous rassurer sur ce point.
Répondez-nous sur une question
très précise: oui aux transitions
et aux synchronisations
Europe-France, mais ne touchez pas
à l'article 13-13-1.
Il est le contrat de confiance
entre notre pays et l'agriculture.
Il est très clairement la garantie
de la santé des sols, de la terre
et de la santé des hommes.
Les socialistes sont très attachés
aux institutions républicaines et
scientifiques en matière de
sécurité nucléaire et sanitaire.
Garantissez-nous que vous n'allez
pas remettre en cause nos
institutions.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Marc Fesneau, ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la
Souveraineté alimentaire.
- Marc Fesneau: Merci beaucoup.
En vous entendant, monsieur
Potier, je me disais que vous
n'avez pas la même lecture de ce
que j'ai dit.
La seule chose que j'ai pu dire et
exprimer, je continue à
l'exprimer: c'est la nécessité de
synchroniser nos décisions
nationales avec les décisions
européennes.
Cela ne me paraît pas une
injonction contradictoire avec la
volonté que nous partageons de
procéder à une réduction de
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires en France.
Mais comme nous sommes dans le
même marché commun, si nous
procédons à des décisions qui sont
bêtement désynchronisées des
autres, nous allons perdre en
compétitivité et en souveraineté.
Nos voisins européens se feront
alors forts.
Nous avons besoin de changer de
méthode.
Je le répète, il faut faire en
sorte que tout le monde se sente
impliqué dans la nécessité de la
réduction des produits
phytosanitaires dans la santé et
de l'environnement.
Si on n'a pas les deux pendants et
les deux éléments, cela ne va pas
marcher.
La volonté qui est la nôtre n'est
pas différente de cela.
Il n'est pas question de remettre
en cause quoi que ce soit.
Il est question de remettre en
cause une méthode.
Tout le monde est comptable de la
souveraineté et de la santé de
tout le monde.
La méthode qui a été définie avec
madame la Première ministre est
une méthode simple: regarder,
produit par produit, molécule par
molécule, filière par filière, où
sont les problèmes.
On a perdu de la compétitivité sur
les cerises, donc je veux voir les
solutions.
On a besoin de les mettre sur la
table pour sortir avec plus de
facilité.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Jocelyn
Dessigny.
- Jocelyn Dessigny: Merci.
Ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la Transition écologique et de
la Cohésion territoriale, monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
Lors d'une commission d'enquête,
nous avions proposé avec
pertinence différentes mesures,
dont un moratoire et l'annulation
de tous les projets en cours.
Avec plus de 500 éoliennes, mon
département a largement contribué
à l'effort national pour la
transition écologique.
Face à l'inaction du président de
la région des Hauts-de-France,
Xavier Bertrand, le 2 avril
dernier, et 17 maires courageux
ont pris la décision de mener
simultanément une consultation
locale au sujet d'un énième projet
de construction d'éoliennes
géantes de 180 mètres de haut.
Le non l'a emporté.
Vous-même avez été élu maire avec
un taux de participation de
seulement 34,25% des inscrits, ce
qui vous rend également moins
légitime que ce scrutin.
Aujourd'hui, on attend des
pouvoirs publics qu'ils respectent
notre volonté.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à monsieur
Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Monsieur le député Jocelyn
Dessigny, vous évoquez deux
sujets.
Vous avez évoqué le référendum
local et cette consultation
locale.
Je ne suis pas en train de
remettre en cause sa légitimité.
Je ne le prends pas comme une
critique.
Le fond de votre question est bien
sur le nombre et le niveau du parc
éolien.
Agnès Pannier-Runacher a porté
cette loi.
Cela a été l'occasion de nombreux
débats ici.
Pour cela, il faut du nucléaire et
des énergies renouvelables.
Nous avons concentré nos efforts
sur le nucléaire off-shore et sur
le photovoltaïque.
Il ne faut pas que l'éolien
terrestre se traduise par des
crispations supplémentaires sur le
terrain.
Cela a été entendu.
Il faut un avis conforme des
communes.
La possibilité d'avoir des zones
d'exclusion ou de limitation des
collectivités locales a fait
l'objet d'un accord entre
l'Assemblée nationale et Sénat.
Enfin, le concept et la notion
juridique de saturation visuelle,
que vous évoquez en filigrane dans
votre question, cela a été
consacré par la loi et cela
devient un des éléments
d'appréciation de l'autorité
environnementale.
De là où je suis, je ne connais
pas dans le détail les projets
dont vous parlez, mais je sais ce
qu'est l'Etat de droit.
Nous allons continuer à faire de
la consultation ascendante.
Quand les riverains sont contre, à
la fin, les projets ne sortent
pas.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Jocelyn Dessigny: Monsieur le
ministre, devant l'incompréhension
d'un tel refus, un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens pourraient être
suspicieux.
Afin de lever tout autre doute sur
le fonctionnement de l'éolien en
France et par volonté de
transparence, au nom du groupe
Rassemblement National, je demande
à ce qu'une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur le financement
de l'éolien soit mise en place
dans les six mois à venir.
Je vous remercie.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Vincent Thiébaut.
- Vincent Thiébaut: Merci.
La réussite de la plupart de nos
politiques publiques va passer par
les collectivités territoriales,
et c'est un sujet d'aménagement de
territoire, particulièrement dans
la réussite d'un enjeu majeur: la
transition écologique.
Toutefois, cela ne pourra pas se
faire sans un effort soutenu des
territoires.
La fédération des pôles
d'équilibres territoriaux et
ruraux a réaffirmé récemment, dans
une tribune, cette ingénierie
locale.
12.000 élus locaux ont signé cette
tribune.
Il est préconisé le 1% ingénierie.
La Première ministre a évoqué un
fonds dédié à l'ingénierie de 200
millions d'euros.
Que pensez-vous de cette
proposition?
Quelle sera la traduction
opérationnelle du fonds évoqué par
la Première ministre?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Dominique Faure.
- Dominique Faure: Merci.
Monsieur le député Thiébaut, sur
la question de l'ingénierie
territoriale...
Monsieur le député, je vous ai
perdu.
Vous êtes assis.
Merci.
La question est essentielle pour
soutenir l'aménagement et le
développement durable de nos
territoires.
Le gouvernement a dégagé des
moyens inédits, au cours des
dernières années, via la NCT.
Il y a notamment eu 900 chefs de
projet et plusieurs programmes
d'ingénierie.
S'agissant du 1% ingénierie, c'est
une proposition qui est portée par
plusieurs associations d'élus,
dont l'Association nationale des
pôles territoriaux et des pays.
Nous avons lu attentivement la
tribune.
C'est une proposition qui a aussi
été formulée par deux sénateurs.
Je les ai reçus le 28 février
dernier.
Ils m'ont remis un rapport.
Cette proposition nécessite une
étude approfondie pour pouvoir
imaginer les scénarios crédibles.
Mais ce 1% a vraiment du sens.
Serait-il dédié à l'ingénierie de
projet, pour lequel les crédits
d'investissement étaient prévus?
Peuvent-ils être mutualisés entre
plusieurs collectivités et, si
oui, à quel niveau?
C'est l'objet de cette étude.
Dans l'attente de ces résultats,
je vous rappelle que différents
dispositifs visent d'ores et déjà
à renforcer l'ingénierie dans le
cadre de toute la transition
territoriale que nous sommes
amenés à traverser.
Le fonds vert en est un exemple
frappant.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
- Vincent Thiébaut: Ce sont
souvent les derniers élèves qui en
pâtissent le plus.
Nous sommes très sensibles à ce
sujet.
Merci pour votre réponse.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à Jiovanny William.
- Jiovanny William: Merci
beaucoup.
Le dernier rapport de madame la
défenseure des droits confirme ce
que nous savons tous déjà.
Elle porte le triste constat de
décisions de justice non
effectuées.
Cet ensemble participe au
non-respect du droit et de la
justice.
Notre actualité locale à la
Martinique et à la Guadeloupe est
un exemple de ces
dysfonctionnements.
Nous vous avons adressé une lettre
ouverte le 6 avril dernier
concernant un justiciable placé en
détention provisoire en
Martinique.
Cet homme a été autorisé à se
rendre au chevet de sa fille
hospitalisée et gravement malade,
mais il n'a pu y aller qu'une
seule fois.
Je sais que votre cabinet a
répondu à mon collègue sur
l'interprétation de cette
ordonnance, mais il y a lieu de
relever des difficultés liées à
l'application des décisions
judiciaires urgentes.
Je ne suis pas ici pour en faire
un procès politique, mais pour
vous signaler les
dysfonctionnements structurels des
services dont vous avez la charge.
Sachant qu'il s'agit d'un sujet
qui concerne également le
ministère de l'Intérieur, puisque
notre particularité résulte du
fait que ces services de transfert
et d'escorte sont assurés à la
fois par la gendarmerie et la
police nationale.
Les syndicats pénitentiaires ont
exprimé leur souhait d'assurer ces
missions pour plus d'efficacité
avec les moyens qui s'imposent.
Par cette occasion, je vous
rappelle que nous, parlementaires
ultramarins, avons saisi votre
cabinet pour travailler sur la
question de la justice dans nos
territoires.
Nous avons des propositions
concrètes à vous faire.
Pouvez-vous nous assurer que vous
recevrez les parlementaires
ultramarins pour traiter en
profondeur cette télématique?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci.
La parole est à monsieur Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
- Eric Dupond-Moretti: Merci.
Bienvenue à la Chancellerie, quand
vous le souhaitez, pour évoquer
les propositions que vous avez à
me faire.
S'agissant de la situation
particulière de votre concitoyen,
il est donc détenu.
Il a demandé au juge d'instruction
l'autorisation de se rendre au
chevet de sa petite fille âgée de
trois ans et demi et atteinte
d'une pathologie que l'on peut
qualifier de très lourde.
Très vite, dans les heures qui ont
suivi la saisine, le juge
d'instruction a répondu
positivement.
C'est une autorisation
exceptionnelle, selon le juge.
Le détenu devait réintégrer
l'établissement pénitentiaire
après la visite.
Il y a eu une difficulté
d'exécution.
Dès le lendemain, il y a eu une
nouvelle saisine.
Dans les heures qui ont suivi, le
juge a rendu une ordonnance.
Le préfet, la justice, le
ministère de l'Intérieur et le
ministère de la Justice ont fait
en sorte que cet homme puisse
voir sa petite fille très vite.
Si de nouvelles autorisations
doivent intervenir, elles ne se
feront pas sur une auto-saisine.
Vous rappelez dans la lettre que
l'homme est présumé innocent.
Ce rappel est superfétatoire.
Pour le reste, je serai tout à
fait ravi de vous recevoir et
d'analyser les différentes
propositions que vous me ferez.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La parole est à monsieur Sylvain
Carrière.
- Sylvain Carrière:
Merci.
L'heure est grave.
La sécheresse record de l'été
dernier, c'est 33 jours de vagues
de chaleur.
Cette année, après 32 jours sans
pluie, on compte déjà 20.000 ha de
brûlés.
Je veux rendre hommage aux 200
pompiers mobilisés ces derniers
jours dans l'Hérault pour lutter
contre le feu.
En 2020, vous avez annoncé une
baisse de 10% des prélèvements à
l'horizon 2025, mais rien n'a
changé, rien n'est planifié.
Vous réitérez vos fausses
promesses pour 2027.
Vous ne connaissez que les effets
d'annonce.
Vous êtes à la botte des
industriels, qui accaparent toutes
les richesses.
La sécheresse
risque de devenir la prochaine
pandémie.
Il n'y a aucun vaccin pour la
guérir.
C'est une annonce de l'ONU.
Vous êtes en guerre contre le
dispositif de la raison qui
appelle à rationaliser les usages
et garantir l'accès à l'eau
potable.
Vous êtes en guerre contre les
Mahorais, ces Français qui sont
30% à ne pas être raccordés à
l'eau courante.
Vous êtes en guerre pour la grosse
industrie, en croisade seul et
contre tous, sur un sujet qui vous
dépasse, à l'heure où la réponse
doit et ne sera que collective.
Qu'attendez-vous pour décréter
l'état d'urgence sanitaire à
Mayotte?
Qu'attendez-vous pour vous occuper
des 500.000 Français qui n'ont pas
d'eau chez eux?
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Je vous
remercie.
La parole est à Christophe Béchu.
- Christophe Béchu: Merci.
Ne pas connaître un sujet est un
avantage dont il ne faut pas
abuser.
Sincèrement, enchaîner autant de
contrevérités en si peu de temps,
c'est une insulte.
Je comprends que cela fasse
réagir vos collègues.
- Gabriel Attal: Monsieur le
député Labaronne, on met souvent
en lumière le travail des
gendarmes et des policiers, mais
rarement le travail des douaniers.
Travail exceptionnel pour protéger
la frontière, pour protéger les
marchandises.
C'est un honneur pour moi d'être
le patron des douaniers et de leur
donner les moyens d'agir
efficacement.
J'avais déjà annoncé les chiffres
de l'année.
J'ai fixé une très grande
priorité, c'est la lutte contre le
trafic et contre la contrebande de
tabac et de cigarettes dans notre
pays.
Il y a un chiffre particulièrement
édifiant:
400 tonnes de tabac de contrebande
saisis en 2021.
C'est aussi lié à des trafics qui
augmentent.
Or, le trafic de tabac dans notre
pays, c'est une plaie pour la
sécurité, car cela finance des
réseaux criminels qui mettent en
péril la sécurité des Français.
C'est aussi une plaie pour la
santé et c'est une plaie pour le
réseau des buralistes.
Nous en avons besoin partout sur
le territoire pour créer du lien
social.
C'est aussi une plaie pour les
finances publiques.
Le trafic augmente.
Nous avons démantelé cinq usines
de contrefaçon de tabac sur le sol
national, l'année dernière.
Ces usines pouvaient fabriquer
jusqu'à 1 million de cigarettes de
contrebande par jour.
Jeudi, je présenterai le premier
projet de loi dédié à la douane
depuis 60 ans.
Le coeur de ce projet de loi,
c'est l'encadrement du droit de
visite douanier qui nous a été
demandé par le Conseil
constitutionnel.
Nous avons beaucoup travaillé avec
Eric Dupond-Moretti.
Je crois que nous avons trouvé le
bon équilibre.
Nous allons aller loin pour
moderniser et renforcer l'action
de nos douaniers.
Nous voulons détecter les convois
qui arrivent sur le territoire
avec des stupéfiants ou avec du
tabac.
Nous aurons aussi des moyens
supplémentaires pour détecter ce
qui se passe en ligne, avec la
création d'une réserve des
douanes.
Nous avons donc un plan majeur du
renforcement de l'action de nos
douaniers et nous pouvons être
fiers de l'action remarquable qui
est la leur partout sur notre
territoire.
- Yaël Braun-Pivet: Merci
beaucoup.
La séance est suspendue.